so it's even for women though it's like
they're not conscious of their strategy
of strategic pluralism
you know they're just in strategic
pluralism as the evolutionary
psychology idea that the the alpha seed
beta needs you know
dynamic is is is is
illustrated in what's called strategic
pluralism which is that most women can't
find a guy to satisfy
all their genetic desires for mating
plus all their needs for provisioning
okay
so they end up what they end up doing is
sort of going for guys for the
the sex right for the desire and then
they sort of settle with the guy that
they think that they can live with
and that'll help them meet their
milestones and all that stuff but this
is
all primal and unconscious you know this
is happening
in their hind brain it's a driver so
without
having some sort of you know education
on this stuff
which of course modern gynocentric
society feminism does not educate women
on these things
they don't know that this is their
operating system they don't know this is
happening
they get in a relationship and they're
told all these things they they're told
you know that guy that you were really
hot for that you kind of had all the
roller coaster coaster of emotions with
no
becky you don't want to settle with that
guy you don't want to marry that guy
you're just going to have a really
tough you know he's probably going to
stay with you he'll probably cheat
so you know you need to find the nice
guy who matches your checklist
and this and that poor nice guy goes
with her
you know and he's like oh he thinks he
won the lottery you know becky finally
wants to date him you know
she's been ignoring him for since high
school now becky finally wants to go out
with them and you know he thinks he won
a prize and
she really realizes you know the error
of her ways and she's going to settle
with him
and then they get along the relationship
meet some milestones and she's just not
happy
and so she's trying to figure it out and
no one's telling her the answers
they're telling her that if she just has
a transactional relationship with this
dude
that then she's gonna be happy and then
and then she does all this
you know he's like a clean the kitchen
how about that blow job that i only get
on my birthday
and then and she's like i just did it
right right like she's like like at what
point did
like becky when she was at the foam
cannon party
and ibiza think to herself when she was
having a threesome with
pablo and juan that uh oh wait hang on a
second we got to get our love languages
hatched out here before we start having
these gymnastics going on over there
from the chandelier
yeah before it gets spit roasted yeah
can we spend some quality
time before you spit in my mouth pablo i
need to get this
uh quiz taken so that we can establish
what love language we're gonna have here
during this transaction that we're going
to execute
pablo can you tell me words of
affirmation
behind me will i get physical touch from
your friend in front of me you over
there you do
like what do you do you have like a room
you know the train ready to go
are you over there you're going to do
physical touch you're going to do words
of affirmation
yeah yeah and that's and that's that's
the thing and
the ignores it completely misunderstands
women i mean women can have
competing ideas and often multiple
competing ideas at once
in their head i mean it's kind of a
talent you know what i mean and so
if you ask a girl like what her love
language is her answer
if she's thinking about the socially
acceptable
provisioning beta dynamic answer she's
going to give you one set of answers
but her answer for chad that she's you
know
that's going to see on the side and
sleep with on the same night and you
know
not tell her mom about that guy yeah
that's that's a different answer
the only answer that you guys need to
concern yourself with is does she have
genuine burning desire for me if she has
that
everything else pretty much takes care
of itself the minute that you start
taking these quiz to negotiate desire
between
the two of you in a relationship you're
you're putting yourself in the position
of beta bucks it's it's like it's just
never going to end well
you